everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm and today I'm gonna be
going over three chess engines you may
not be familiar with that should help
you improve your chess game the first
one's gonna be on my website it's more
of a basic chess engine but it's very
easy to use the second one is gonna be
an AI version that actually digs in and
tells you where you should be moving
what's your opponent's thinking the best
lines gives you a lot more explanation
and last one is gonna be if you wanted
to learn how to download your own chess
engine have its own UI instead of going
out and having to buy an expensive one
you can actually get it for free online
so that's we're gonna be going over the
main reason is because the top two
questions that I get asked all the time
or one Kevin how do I get better at
chess and the second one is do you
recommend in a chess software these kind
of go hand-in-hand because outside I'm
just saying to get better just watch all
the software and spend a lot of time on
the website analyzing your own games is
a great way to improve if you're just
playing chess and you're never really
analyzing your games and looking at
positions and seeing where did I go
wrong or how could I do better you're
probably not gonna progress as much as
you should so giving into chess engines
is a great way to analyze your games in
different positions so that you can
improve your chess game so the first one
we're gonna look at is on the chess
website calm now hopefully if you're
watching this video you're familiar with
the website but if not it is just the
chess website calm I will have the links
for all of these chess engines in the
description below but if you come to the
website you can scroll down there's
going to be a button here that says
chess analysis you can click on that
it's gonna take you to the chess engine
on the website now there's a couple ways
that you can use this one is to paste in
a PG in game and PGN simply means it's
going to show all the moves in a game
typically if you play wherever you're
playing it will ask you if you want to
download that game it's going to
download it as a PG and now at the
bottom here it's gonna ask you a couple
things search depth 20 moves is default
and time limit it's one second
I usually go ninety-nine moves here and
then for time limit you may want to do
something like for the more seconds you
have in air the deeper analysis is going
to do and you can hit analyze here it's
going to analyze this game and then you
can go through every single move in
gain and see what the computer thinks is
going on so in this case you could see a
strength evaluation of plus point three
that means that white is winning by
approximately one third of a pond so not
a huge advantage here but if you go
later on and start to look at other move
so you can see for each of these that's
analyzing it for about four seconds the
strength evaluation White's winning by a
little bit more and you can go even
further along and you can see that after
queenie seven that whites winning by a
lot more by four point three that that's
a significant advantage and then you can
go back and look at different moves and
see where did black go wrong where did
they make a mistake and it will also
give you recommended line so instead of
making the mistake they made maybe you
want to go through and see where they
could have gone another option you have
is to do a custom board so instead of
doing a move order history you can click
on custom board and you can set up the
board however you want now if you want
to do a couple moves you can click on a
piece and then move forward as you can
set up the board this way or if you
wanted to clear the board you could hit
clear board it's gonna start the game
with two kings here and then I can just
click the material I once I can stick it
on the board maybe I want a pawn here as
well Queen here and then you can see
it's white to move you can change that
and I can hit analyze and it's going to
analyze this position and then recommend
what white should do and you can see
strength evaluation white has a
significant advantage plus twenty point
two it's also going to give you a
recommended line in case moves would
continue so you have Queen to e5 taking
that material here King b7 does it
exactly have to move like this bill show
you how it could continue from here and
why it's probably just gonna March the
pawn up the board get another Queen
checkmate pretty easily from there so
that is the chess engine on the chess
website calm now beyond the chess
website calm there are some very
powerful tools out there one of them
that I really like is to coach a set
calm will have a link in the description
below and the reason I like this in our
recommended to people is it explains
positions to people many times
especially if you're getting into chess
you don't even know what to do with some
of the chess software out there it tells
you that white winning in position and
it gives you one recommended line but
you don't really know how to improve
from that you just say okay I see that
this line is better it says this
actually explains it so if you click on
import and there's also other options
you can you can play you can set up a
specific board but if you want to import
one of your own games you can paste in a
game so a PG and or an at the end so at
the same place that you would typically
get a PG in and will say do you want to
copy this position you can click yes and
typically that's gonna give you an F en
I can paste this in and click import and
it's going to give me this board set up
and then I can click the code game and
it's going to decode this for me the
specific position and recommend
something to me and then tell me why so
it says in this position the best move
is rook to c1 and you may look at this
first often say the knight can take here
on e7 okay that makes a lot of sense
here if they recapture with their knife
that's fine but the Queen can recapture
here
how's that looks like a good move but
here it's saying in this position the
best move is rook to c1 it starts to
tell you all the reasons why but it gets
even better because you can click on
this plus button and it starts to break
it down even more so the idea is white
wants to checkmate by starting out with
Knight takes on e7 but black and play
Queen takes on b1 then after the Knight
takes here you can start to see what
will happen so playing a c1 tells you
exactly before E
[Music]
you know after you play c1 what are
things that you're gonna be looking for
in this case it's if it was black smooth
they're gonna be looking to play Queen
takes on b1 or queen takes on g6 good
moves for white in this position it says
hey really in this case there's only one
good move and that's rook here to c1
sometimes it'll give you lots of options
and you can choose which path you want
to go down but in this case that says
the best move is rook to c1
it also has different plans so one plan
is Knight to e7 you have Queen takes on
e7
but it's telling you hey those are your
plans but the best move still is rook to
c1 it also has functionalities so we're
all the different pieces can go and the
different concepts for you to be
thinking about so when I'm talking about
chess and I'm describing situations I'm
usually going over concept so things
like getting your Knights in a position
where they're in the center of the board
and they're controlling more squares
getting your rooks to your opponent's
seventh-ranked those types of concepts
they're gonna start to break all that
down for you for every single position
so it's a great way to analyze your
games and start to see what they
recommend and why they recommend it if
you wanted to import an entire game you
can do that as well I can click on
import I can paste in a PG in it's going
to load that you can even recognize the
tournament it is from I click on imports
here and then you can see I click on the
code game and it starts to analyze the
entire game right here and you can even
see if you scroll over each move here
it's going to tell you how the game went
meaning by move 23 you can see that
white had a slight advantage 1.16
equates to about a pawn advantage and
you can see at the very end here it went
from one to 5.7 a so we can start to
click on a specific move you can do it
over here as well and you can analyze
that specific moves you if you click on
this you see it says explain the
position on the board in depth
so that's where we really got into
finding out what different options White
has what options that black has what are
the different threats that white has to
worry about and why it recommends the
moves that it does so this is a great
tool to both analyze positions as well
as an entire game figuring out what's
going on how could I have done better
what are the things I should be thinking
about and all does it very very quickly
with a very nice user interface so some
of the other things that you should be
using in this you can play as well so
people always ask me where do you go to
play against a computer or something if
you're already in here you can use this
as well you have lots of difficulties
that you can choose in here by default
it's gonna have you in the middle at
five but you can say I want to play the
computer hard any of that again you can
analyze that game if you want to see
where you went wrong see what the
computer was doing so lots of different
options in the code chess comm the last
option I'm going to show you if you
actually wanted to run your own chess
engine on your computer this is a little
bit more advanced but if you are looking
for something like this it's extremely
easy so I think once you start to do it
you'll see that it's not very difficult
at all and this can replace if you were
thinking about going in buying some real
expensive software my guess is that this
will solve what you're doing and it
doesn't cost anything so with that said
you can come here to stock fish chess
org if you want to download the Windows
version you can download here or you can
just click on download it does have
multiple options you can get it for
Windows Mac Android or Linux I use
Windows so I'm gonna be showing what
that looks like on Windows but notice it
says you will need to use your own UCI
compatible chess program there's a lot
of different
UCI compatible chess programs you can
just do a quick Google search if you
want to a lot of people like arena chess
I think it's fine I've used it in the
past and so that's what I'm gonna be
demoing here but just know that you have
multiple options out there
and many of these arena included they
have their own chess engine so you don't
have to use stock fish but it is one of
the more popular ones out there so I
just want to show everyone what it would
look like if you wanted to both download
your own UCI compatible chess program as
well as use something like stock fish
now after you download arena and you
unzip the file you will see a folder
structure that looks like this I've put
it in a folder called chess software but
you could put it anywhere on your
computer and then you can just run the
application and then you will see this
interface come up right here so there's
lots of stuff that you can do in here
I'm not gonna do an entire in-depth
video on all the different things you
can do in here if you would like to see
that video you can definitely let me
know but there's a few things that I
will touch on the first one is that you
can you can play the computer that may
be obvious but you can also put in
different positions so I still have that
PGN on my clipboard you can put that
position in here
or that entire game in here and then you
can start to go through and look at that
game and then you can analyze that game
you can click on the analyze here and it
will start to analyze and show you what
it would recommend for the next move so
that can be extremely helpful if you're
looking for that but this currently is
using the engine that comes with it so
this is the arena engine if you wanted
to use the stock fish engine you can
come up here to engines and say install
new engine and then it's going to ask
you where you want to to get that engine
now I've already come in and downloaded
the stock fish and then I have unzip
that file as well but then you can just
find on your computer where that is I
can click on stock fish right here I can
click on open you can see it's a
duplicate named only because I have
already loaded this up but then like
just say yes I want to load that one and
then you can now see that the engine
it's running is stockfish now if I come
up here to engines I could say the load
engine it's going to show you all of the
engines that I have it already had the
stock fished in that's why you see the
the duplicate here but it has by default
a lot of different options so very easy
to go get stock fish then have your own
UI like we have here and then run it so
you can analyze an entire game you can
analyze positions if you wanted to set
something up if you want to set up a
position I can say yes I want to do that
I can clear the board if I want to and
then it tells you here exactly how to
set up the board stuff if I want my King
here and then using my right button I
can put the King here and then with
pawns I could start to set up the board
I can put these over here however you
want to set the board setup you can do
that and then click OK and then you can
analyze this position again as we talked
about there's other options that you
have here
I'm not gonna go over every single
option that you have but this is a
pretty robust tool and you saw how
quickly I did that didn't cost him any
money to do that so if you are more
advanced and you're looking for a chess
engine to run yourself without paying a
lot of money I definitely recommend
something like this going and finding a
engine that you like and then a UI that
you like because again there's lots of
different options you don't just have to
use the one I'm showing you right here
so hopefully this was helpful there's
just so many different options I'm
showing three just because I don't
honestly want the video to be an hour
long but hopefully this will give you an
idea of what's out there let me know if
there's others that you like or if
there's a specific one you want me to go
more in depth about and tell you how I
may have used it in the past or would
use it in the future if I was you know
early in chess trying to get better and
just trying to learn so thank you guys
so much for watching and I will see you
guys in the next video